[Música]
bienvenidos a este especial de france 24
en español les saluda luis méndez
zurich luego de 5 años en manos de la
oposición la asamblea nacional de
venezuela pasará al control del
oficialismo en 2021 un hecho que para
muchos podría profundizar la crisis
política que ha crecido en los últimos
años la comunidad internacional se
mantiene expectante pues supone un
control total de los poderes por parte
de la administración de nicolás maduro y
sin conocer de manera clara qué acciones
podría llevar adelante la oposición para
entender más sobre este particular tema
veamos el siguiente informe
el 6 de diciembre de 2020 el gran polo
patriótico bajo el cual participan los
principales partidos del oficialismo se
quedó con la mayoría de curules en el
parlamento al conseguir 253 diputados
más tres indígenas de los 277 en juego
en medio de una abstención que ronda el
70% el triunfo le permite al gobierno
tomar nuevamente el control del único
poder que ostentaba la oposición y que
no dominaba hace un lustro
cinco años después tengo que salir ha de
ser tenemos una nueva asamblea nacional
producto del voto popular el 6 de
diciembre de 2015 la opositora mesa de
la unidad democrática había logrado
obtener 112 diputados de 167 curules a
elegir
[Aplausos]
sin embargo sería el inicio de una
profundización en la crisis política
denuncias de presuntas irregularidades
en el estado amazonas al sur de
venezuela evitaron que la oposición
consolidar a la llamada mayoría
calificada quedamos así mera pareja y
ellos sacaron una diferencia bueno por
un conjunto de irregularidades así lo sé
así lo creo y así es ante ese escenario
el tribunal supremo de justicia electo
por la asamblea nacional saliente
suspendió a tres diputados de los 112 y
una nueva elección nunca se llevará a
cabo para presionar la oposición
juramento a los parlamentarios pese a la
sentencia del tsj el resultado fue la
declaratoria de desacato de la asamblea
nacional ninguno de todos sus actos
en consecuencia dos años después de la
victoria opositora en 2015 nicolás
maduró convocó elecciones para llamar a
una asamblea nacional constituyente una
especie de órgano legislativo paralelo
dominado por el chavismo
pero la batalla entre el ejecutivo y el
legislativo se profundizó cuando juan
guaidó asumió la presidencia de la
asamblea a principios de 2019 poco
tiempo después se autoproclama haría
presidente interino de venezuela bajo el
argumento de llamar a elecciones libres
y tras el desconocimiento de los
comicios presidenciales realizados en
mayo de 2018 para una parte de la
población la nueva asamblea nacional de
mayoría oficialista abre una esperanza
para lograr estabilidad política y poder
hacer frente a la crisis económica y
social que afecta al país para otros es
la consumación de un fraude orquestado
por el chavismo que permite a lo que
califican como una dictadura hacerse con
todos los poderes del estado
para recordar que una parte de la
oposición venezolana optó por no
participar en los comicios celebrados en
diciembre de 2020 algo similar a lo
ocurrido en 2005 y que dejó la asamblea
nacional completamente oficialista
adicionalmente para el período
legislativo 2021 2026 se elevó en 100 el
número de escaños es decir casi un 66%
respecto al parlamento del año 2015 en
la asamblea del año 2015 la oposición
contó con 112 diputados antes de la
suspensión de tres de ellos dejando el
número total en 109 y sin la mayoría
calificada
para analizar más sobre este tema veamos
la bienvenida antonio de la cruz
director ejecutivo de inter-american
trend y además especialista en economía
y petróleo saludo señor de la cruz
bienvenido a frank 2024 muchas gracias
por la invitación le pregunto qué
impacto tendrá en la actual situación
política de venezuela una nueva asamblea
nacional con la mayoría oficialista
el impacto que va a tener es que en los
59 países que desconocieron esta
elección el 6 de diciembre que apoyan a
juan guaidó
entre la asamblea nacional quedó electa
en 2015 va a desconocer la el 5 de enero
entonces vamos a tener otra vez una
situación donde los países que apoyan
nicolás maduros como rusia china irán
turquía y otros en términos de que
reconocen esa asamblea se proyecta el
pse de diciembre va a tomar lección y de
acuerdo a esas acciones legislativas el
país para empezar a tomar decisiones
sobre todo en el área de lo que se
conoce con la ley anti bloqueo que va a
permitirle al banco las maduro poder
hacer vender parte de los activos que
fueron nacionalizados durante 2002 y
2012 en la época en el gobierno de una
administración de hugo chávez
en pasar ahora a ser vendido sobre todo
en el sector petrolero la participación
en las empresas mixtas y esto le va a
permitir a nicolás maduro tener un
oxígeno en el punto de vista con
respecto a las sanciones que ha impuesto
estados unidos en la parte de pedevesa
entonces vamos a tener otra vez una las
dos partes una parte que se dice ya y es
considerada como en la legitima por 59
países una elección democrática y la de
nicolás maduro que es reconocida por el
sector te lo pone
ahora la elección del pasado 6 de
diciembre estuvo marcada por una alta
abstención en 2015 votaron más de 14
millones de personas en 2020 la
participación se ubicó en 6 millones 251
mil 80 electores la oposición ha
respondido a estos comicios con una
consulta popular no vinculante y
recientemente la actual asamblea
nacional anunció que extendía por un año
sus funciones escuchemos declarar formal
y legalmente la continuidad
constitucional del poder legislativo
para mantener la vigencia de la
constitución y la defensa en nuestro
pueblo y su exigencia de libertad sean
antonio como podríamos analizar la alta
abstención y qué impacto podría
representar el movimiento que está
haciendo la oposición
en términos de la abstención se debe a
que en venezuela en ese momento la
motivación para participar en estos
procesos electorales recordemos que la
unión europea y estos 59 países te
conocieron es álex por lo tanto no hubo
una participación de parte tampoco de lo
que encabeza juan guaidó como la
asamblea nacional electa en el pib 15
solamente un sector pequeño él participó
dentro conocido como la mesita en
venezuela es un grupo básicamente a
personas que son de la oposición y que
participaron entonces que tienen tenemos
que un desconocimiento en términos
vuelvo a insistir internacionalmente y
que significa que en la consulta popular
realizada entre el siguiente y el 12 que
también tuvo una participación en
términos similares si hablamos en 6.7
millones de son entonces que quiere
decir que ambos estamos en una posición
ninguno de los dos somete a la otra
parte qué quiere decir esto en venezuela
la solución tiene que ser una solución
que convoque a las grandes mayorías
porque recordemos que el padrón
electoral fueron fe son 20 millones de
electores y solamente participaron en
una consulta 6 millones
y en la elección del parlamento 6
millones y poquito más del que quiere
decir esto que hay un gran sector en el
centro que está
viendo cómo resuelve en el día a día
porque hoy venezuela siempre como usted
conoce de la parte de la alta inflación
escasez de alimentos hobbits y entonces
es el ciudadano de a pie no se siente
identificado y con la solución que
propuso nicolás maduro ni con la
solución que ha propuesto cuando y bajo
este panorama que se está presentando
actualmente con un control oficialista
de la asamblea nacional podríamos hablar
de un nicolás maduro fortalecido para su
próximo proceso
sí sí la oposición de juan guaidó y el
gobierno interino no logra con con la
nueva administración de los eeuu joe
punk que asume el 20 de enero un blog
una convergencia en términos de buscar
una solución multilateral entre la unión
europea y eeuu para presionar al collage
marido futuro a una elección
presidencial y parlamentaria nueva para
legitimar los poderes como nicolás
maduro logra sostenerse a lo largo del
2021 donde va está pautada las
elecciones de gobernador y alcalde
y obligaría de alguna manera a la
oposición a participar porque la unión
europea buscando una solución pacífica
electoral va a ir a supervisar a
observar esta elección y entonces en ese
sentido nicolás maduro podría seguir
manteniendo la la presidencia y ahí
mismo se legitimaría a la asamblea
nacional y veríamos que en venezuela la
solución electoral pasaría por un camino
que le llevaría
2025 es cuando en el 2024 hay la
elección presidencial de 2025 asuma la
presidencia nueva en el país ahora
hablemos un poco con los problemas que
ha derivado de toda esta crisis política
primer lugar una falta o problemas en
los servicios básicos y también una
escasez de gasolina brevemente señor
antonio podría venezuela solventar este
problema de escasez de combustible en
los próximos meses oa largo plazo
en los próximos meses la solución es
importar gasolina porque no ha logrado
resolver la destrucción de la industria
petrolera esto es en ese sentido la
refinada y las refinerías no están
produciendo suficiente venezuela la
producción normal eran 330 mil barriles
de combustible de gasolina y hoy se
están produciendo apenas el 10% 30.000
barriles entre 30.000 a 50.000 barriles
y entonces ocurre que la demanda que
está en 120 va a tener que se importa en
ese sentido va a tener eso espero
no le hayan tibro que se va a entregar
las asociaciones va a poder entregarles
a chevron repsol en dos de las
participaciones que tienen y ellos van a
entrar al país en ese sentido para poder
levantar a finales del próximo año
francisca petrolera y favorecerá en ese
sentido la escasez
entre lucera es combustible que vive el
país
muchísimas gracias en el antonio por
haber participado con nosotros en este
especial a todos ustedes gracias por la
sintonía sigan con más de france 24 y
france 24 puntocom
[Música]